Kevin Durant of the Warriors up by six
today by the Lakers here they come it's
for our two kcp in the middle goodness
the heat goes up Kevin Durant says I owe
Kevin said I block two plus the game guy
can get to that can i Larry now said
yeah you can get to it all right get
this you talk about being on a launch
pad in and out for Harris the well stays
answering
[Music]
[Applause]
this high-speed replay brought to you by
AT&T no well the offensive rebound of
the big jam that was provocative
four-year player at Kansas State where
he averaged that's a bad pass board
we'll talk it
lazy pass out there midcourt getting
ready for all-star weekend as he brings
it down and back up for to his cousins
has left he has two fouls that's why
he's out as Oladipo went right around
Cunningham really powerful move to get
to the rim and you can see the explosion
I don't look quickly until the other
side of the rim over Anthony Davis who
came late Victor Oladipo was able to
finish strong